Those downtime
worries goodbye, my friend.
Quality
and uptime,
the stacks will descend
with a platform
that
Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I'm
your host, David Flanagan,
also known across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today is another episode of Rawkode live, the
show where we get hands on keyboards and
take a live look at cloud native and
cloud native adjacent technologies.
And the title of today's episode is DevOps
on Autopilot,
which is a bold claim, so I'm very
excited to see Qovery
and be joined by the CEO,
Romeric.
Hey. How's it going?
Hey. I'm good, David. Thanks for having me.
How are My pleasure. Thank you for joining
me.
That's an amazing song like that you get,
like, for the intro.
It's crazy that you can do now with
Jet AI.
Yeah. I started doing that, I think, like,
four or five episodes ago. I mean, AI
tools are getting so good now and generating
music is
I mean, I I I generally enjoy them.
I I I think they're little catchy numbers.
I mean, they're not, you know, pushing the
envelope or anything like that, but music doesn't
always have to. So I think it's nice
that we get a special little,
you know, song to commemorate our time together
today. So That's amazing. That's amazing. Especially that
I was, like, doing actually, so it's completely
out of topic, but I did practice. I
did, like, some music, produce music, and you
know how much time it takes just to
get that.
That's crazy. Like, today, you can just, like,
in a few clicks, few prompt,
just get something that is ready to be
uploaded.
Crazy. Yeah. One
prompt that are rigos over and over again.
I tweak it for each tool and and
and each guest, and I'd like the music
to be somewhat familiar. So it's all kind
of similar,
you know, mellow, electronic, chilled beat,
but it works really well. And, also, it's
really good at metal. I don't wanna, like,
just deviate right on the music path in
the AI chat already, but, yeah, you could
do some pretty powerful things with that. Anyway,
people are here to learn about DevOps and
Autopilot. They wanna learn about your tool, Qovery,
and they wanna learn about you. So could
you do us a favor and tell us
the history and a little bit of flavor
of Ruric?
Yeah. Absolutely.
So just quickly introduce me introducing myself. So
I'm Omar, IT, and cofounder of Qovery. I
used to be a software
engineer, DevOps engineer, like, for a long time.
Now I can
no longer say that because I've been doing
that, like, for years now.
I'm still practicing. I still have, like, some,
like, open source project that I'm just getting
my hand on. But, anyway
so, yeah, basically, what we do at Qovery
is that we we try just to make
sure that developers are much more, like, autonomous
in their day to day journey. You know,
that they are not the most, like, proficient
in infrastructure management, like, deploying the applications. All
of that
is something still under by mostly DevOps engineers
or actually so or at least, like, people
that they are familiar with infrastructure. And what
we do provide is the platforms that helps,
like, any developer to deploy their application in
their own cloud account. And that's something that
is quite interesting because
I'm pretty sure you're familiar with Fly and,
like, all the other paths, so platform as
a service. And, actually, you can see Qovery
as a platform as a service, but next
generations. Why?
Because, actually, you can run Qovery on your
infrastructure, and Qovery runs on top of Kubernetes.
And this is why it's quite interesting because
you get the benefits of those PaaS platform,
but on top of your infrastructure, basically. So
in just a few minutes, you can start
getting a fully state of the art infrastructure
ready
on your cloud account without any knowledge. So
we have customer in five minutes. They can
do that.
And then you can start deploying and shipping
your your application. And we have really, like,
focused on the developer experience,
what makes, like, our platform
loved by our users. So, yeah, that's
we can dig into all of all of
that, obviously.
Yeah. I mean, back in bold claims, which
I love, you know, there's a lot of
challenges in, you know, the DevOps space, the
platform engineering space, all of this these days.
You know, come software architectures
are getting more complicated and the with the
aim of simplifying,
know, developers'
time, like work on microservices.
But all that complexity doesn't just disappear. It's
getting pushed down that stack to the platform,
the Kubernetes, the cloud providers, etcetera.
And then there's there's just a lot of
tooling needed in a space that people can
still go to sleep at night and not
have to worry about the pager going off
and a whole bunch of other things. And
I feel like we're pushing a lot of
this away from developers too and fragmenting
things. You know, the dev ops teams, the
platform teams are taking on all these responsibilities,
but there's not always that collaboration that dev
encourages us or wants us to kind of
achieve. So yeah. It's interesting times these days
for sure.
Yeah. Absolutely. And, actually, that's quite interesting what
you're saying because we are seeing also, like,
when we started the company,
even Kubernetes were were not, like, the standard.
Like, if we were looking if we are
looking, like, four years back, like, only
companies that they were, like, quite a bleeding
edge were, like, considering and starting using Kubernetes
for real in productions, and now you have
So now it's the it's the standard, like,
the operating system of the cloud. But what
we are seeing now is also, like, even
DevOps engineers that they are proficient
in Kubernetes that they are looking to solutions
just, for the data operations, obviously, but also
to bring, like, a better experience, like, to
the end user because it's quite whole, like,
doing cube control,
comments.
We have done all that.
That's that's pretty good. But in terms of
experience, especially for developers, it's not. So
Yeah.
Definitely.
Hi, Ravi. Thank you for joining us and
saying hello in the chat. Feel free, anyone
else watching, to say hello and let us
know where you're from.
Rawkode,
before we
talk about the problems that Qovery solves and
get hands on with it and show people
how to get started, maybe you could give
us a better information on the the origin
story. Like, did you just wake up one
day and go and go to fix DevOps,
or were you did you have challenges within
your own career or your own job? Like,
I mean, how did you go? Yeah.
I do think it's a classic story.
Yeah. I used to start when I start
working, and this is where I met my
cofounder actually, like, in the HFT, so high
frequency trading. We were, like, managing thousands of
servers, like, globally.
We have a very small team, so quite
proficient in infrastructure management. I used to work
with VMware system, Solaris. So you remember at
the time? So before that, the cloud was
something.
And then I transitioned,
actually, is, like, from the infrastructure side to
software engineering side.
And I was in the position that, okay.
Now I was no longer, like, the ones
that were, like, dealing with tickets coming from
the software engineering department
and provisioning, like, infrastructure, but I was the
one that were claiming for, like, that infrastructure
because I needed just to run my software
to deploy
live, obviously, in productions,
iterate, like, in the development
servers and so on and so forth. And
this is where, like, I just realized that
that's crazy. Like, the experience and when you're
a developer, it's very
it's kind of broken, like, kind of broken.
So I used to move, like, from one
company to another,
like and instead of doing, like, the same
thing, which was, like, at some points, building
a platform internally, like, into the company that
I was working for,
I decided just to say, okay. Instead of,
like, working for the next successful companies,
like, that they they they would hire us
and ask us just to build up, like,
a platform. Okay. Let's build up a product.
Let's deliver that for you to all the
companies that would hire us, and that's the
way we started just basic recovery.
That's that's very, like, very classic. You were
doing that before. You have done that, like,
four years. Now you have the experience, then,
okay, let's speed up a product. But it's
quite challenging because I'm technical,
and now I'm much more, like, in position
where I'm I'm a salesman. I'm spending all
my day just, like, selling the software, talking
to engineer,
to
CTO,
like VPs,
and it's quite interesting, like, the two aspect.
But, anyway, it's completely something
else.
Nice.
What would be you know, if if people
watch us,
what's the
the one use case right off the bat
that anyone's setting right now is struggling trying
to wrangle platforms, DevOps, Kubernetes clusters? Like, what
is that one first use case that you
think Qovery can come in and help people
with? Yeah. Yeah. That's a very good question.
We have a very good use case, and,
actually, it's part of our go to market
strategies since we are accelerating and we're getting
more and more customers. We do focus and
need to focus on one main use case,
but it's basically, like, all companies, like SMBs
companies that they are transitioning
from past platform. They need, at some point,
they are, like, limit limited by, like, the
platform as a service. You are taking hair
or cure, render, fly.
You get the limits because of technical limits,
but also in terms of security, in terms
of compliance, and you need to get into
the, yes, like AWS,
GCP, Azure, scale away. You can name it.
And, basically, here, you have two options. The
first is hiring, like, a DevOps engineer. When
you are, like, a very well funded and
famous company and you want to build up
anyway, like, a a
DevOps engineering team, that there is no problem
for that. But when you are not an
not all companies, they can just afford, like,
hiring a DevOps engineering team. Then this is
why it's quite interesting because Qovery can be
a good very, very strong and good option.
Because in just a few minutes, you get
a state of the art infrastructure with a
very good developer experience. So meaning that you
can just stop right away deploying your vision.
That's a very good use case,
that we are solving with our product, and
that's the main use case because it's production
infrastructure mostly. Yeah.
So Okay.
One more question, and then we'll share my
screen, and we'll actually show people how to
get started.
Obviously, this is 2024. Right? I think the
last twelve to eighteen months have been a
turbulent time for open source projects. He's I
I'm not gonna name them. I'm not gonna
talk about licenses or any of that. Right?
But well, very
does it is open source. Right? So, like,
why
did you go down that route?
That's quite interesting, and I really and I'm
gonna respond to that question. Actually, we don't
even define ourself, like, as an open source
company. But if you look at our GitHub
repository,
we have a lot of and, all deployment
engine is, like, fully open source. And we
have a lot of components that they open
to. But you see, we are not defining
ourself as an open source company. Why?
Because, actually, the product can't work, like, without
the control plane. So we did, like, take
the decisions off, and I did take the
decision of delivering
as much as we can, like, in open
source. So mostly, like, the parts that they
are installed on the infrastructure of our customers
because it's for, like, security, like, reason
and retransparency
because all those elements, there is a lot
of small elements that they are running and
operate they are operated, like, remotely
on their infrastructure, on their Kubernetes cluster, on
their cloud account. And so for transparency,
we have decided just to open source everything,
and we have also, like, a few other
elements, like, tooling that we are using internally
that they are completely open source and they
can be used by our customers. So we
have the open source philosophy at her, and
we do contribute. We are even doing some
contribution.
But we don't define recovery as, like, a
100%,
like, a %
open source product because, actually, the control plane
is,
like, not open source today.
Yeah.
Well, yeah. I mean, I think,
you know, I jumped on to the organization
on GitHub. There's a lot of open source
happening, but, you know, that can only happen
if companies can be sustainably making things open
source. Yeah. I think that's the way to
do it. I mean, it's a very big
challenge right now to Yep. Write all these
amazing products, make them open source. But then,
you know, if you can't pay your bills,
feed your family, then what's the point? So
yeah. Yeah. That makes lot of sense.
But I I like the the trust aspect
and the transparency aspect. I think it is
a really good reason for companies to push
out more open source components even if the
whole thing has an open source because it
does give people trust that,
you know Yeah. And
yeah. Maybe the same as yeah. I'm sorry,
but I'm a I'm a really hard believer
in in open source. I do think I'm
doing this job because of hope open source
and a lot,
and open source is really something. But I
do think and that's another discussion, but
there is a kind, like, of
I would not say a lie, like, in
the industry, but it's really for me, something
that is open to us is really open
to us. Like, really, you can do, you
can take it, you can change it, you
can commercialize it, you can do whatever you
want, and it must be, like, very important.
Otherwise, like, all the software that they are
not, like, in that aspect, you can really
and because of the license aspect and so,
that for me, they are not just they
are not really open, but it's another, again,
like, discussion.
And and I I prefer just to be
super transparent and very clear to our users
as well. Yes. We have components that they
are open source, but cover itself is not
open source. Right. Yeah.
Alright. Awesome.
So shall we show people how to get
started and what Qovery does?
Yes. Let's do it.
Let's let's do it.
Alright. I am on the
Qovery website.
As always, on Rawkode Live, nothing is planned
up front.
I
am in a very nice position where I've
had my eye on Qovery for a while,
but I've never actually kicked the tires on
it. So this is this is legit for
me. This is my first time ever having
to play with it. So we'll go straight
to the get and start to guide,
and we can see there's a this is
quite nice, actually. You've got a whole bunch
of,
like, tracks and scenarios and tutorials.
Wow. I don't often see that. That's awesome.
Very cool. I'm assuming we're gonna start with
that's a nice effect too. So I'm just
gonna geek out over your website. Nice.
I'm assuming we're gonna start with Fumble World.
So
Yeah. And the documentation is open source. We
open source.
Alright. So to begin, I need to get
hub account checked. I can manage that at
least. And we are gonna sign up for
the Qovery web interface.
So let's do that.
Yeah. You will be you will be surprised
by the the the sign up workflow. Let's
let's do it.
Alright.
So I need to pick my cloud.
I have access to to to all of
them, so we'll just go with AWS.
Where's where's DevOps on autopilot?
Why is that not an option?
That's a that's a good one. That's that's
a feedback that we should
Alright. And now I just need to confirm
my email address. I'll do that over here.
Yeah.
And you see yeah. Absolutely.
Actually, you you would be, like, surprised.
There's something.
So when you sign up, you you you
you're blocked by this this page.
So you can confirm, and, usually, what you
get is that an automated message,
Jackie, like, in your mailbox. And then from
that, we give you access
to
the platform so when you reply to it.
But I'm gonna just give you so
I can give you access, actually. So Oh,
okay.
I'm looking for you yourself.
Ah, yes. I can see you.
It's good. An enterprise license, please.
You have to choose your plan then right
after this screen. If you go back now
and you and
and you go and you move forward and
you validate.
Yeah. You have Alright.
Rawkode
Academy.
I'll call this platform.
Alright.
You can start with the free. Yeah. There
is no yeah. No problem. Or you can
take the team plan, then you have no
restriction, actually. It's there is no credit card
needed, so that's good.
Alright. So you got three plans.
Yeah. And up to twenty five years, so
it's three cluster of 20. So okay. I
mean, this is perfect. This is fine for
me. Yeah. Absolutely.
I like it when it's a a pretty
generous free tier.
Yeah.
Alright. I've got Qovery.
Oh. Yeah. You're ready to go.
So I let you just discovering the product
that's quite interesting, actually. I don't want to,
like, influence you all.
Well It's kind of a product session.
I'm just looking at how you interact with
the product.
Wait. Obviously, my eyes are already getting right
to this big create custom button,
which I know I should be back and
follow on the tutorial, but I I'm just
gonna go rogue and, like Yeah.
Let's see. So You are doing, like, a
99%
of all the users, like, share the documentation.
And, actually, it's the it's the well so
that we consider product is that if you
have to look at the documentation to use
it, there is a problem.
But sometime, it's necessary still.
Okay. So, I mean, sensibly, I I mean,
I will do a local machine because I
want to see that workflow. But I clicked
on AWS just to see what the options
were. And we've got our Qovery managed
cluster or self managed cluster. So I just
wanna make sure I understand this correctly.
If I I say I've got my own
company or my own team, we use AWS,
you can I'm assuming if I give you
the right credentials, you're gonna manage a Kubernetes
cluster for us. But if I have an
existing, say, AKS cluster,
I'm assuming we just have self managed and
we deploy some sort of Qovery agent to
it. I mean, is that the right assumption?
That's perfect. That's exactly that.
You get it right. Perfect. With Qovery managed,
I mean, is that in my own AWS
account? Do you run it in your own
account? How does that work? Okay.
Yeah. That's a very good question. And, actually,
so you do just, like, provide the region
the way you wants to deploy. So you
have that.
The credential
so you provide your credentials. So we give
the permissions that we need just to create
the different resources.
But then from that,
you have few other options like Carpenter. You
can install, like, some add ons on your
Kubernetes customs and so forth.
We'll generate so at the end, like, the
work configuration. So we'll create the VPC security
group load balancer,
the the the cluster in, like, multiple availability
zone. So we make sure that you get,
like, a really
fully fledged, like, production infrastructure
running on your cloud account. So it's really
running on your cloud again. And the beauty
here is that you don't have to invest,
like, in day two operation. Meaning, the upgrades
of those clusters, but because
with AWS, you have an upgrade of EKS,
like, every three months. So you need to
spend time, like, on that. And that's a
big value that you get out of discovery
manage, offer because you do once it's done,
you get the power of Kubernetes,
but we are the asset of maintaining that.
Okay. Got it. Let's
keep things simple.
And oh, here we go.
So this is where it's become a a
common theme recently
where people ask me to install command line
applications, and then I have to tell them
that I use Nexus.
So
is it a next package?
No. Is it a static binary?
I do think there is a next
I do think there is a next package,
but it's not maintained by I'm not sure
if it's managed
and still maintained by
the team. I I do know that it
was a customer that did provide that,
but
you can find it on the QWERADI.
I'm gonna just look at that.
Maybe I mean, I can always jump into
a desktop box. It's not a big deal.
Oh, we don't yeah. But it has not
been. Yeah.
Okay.
I found it.
Is 092.8,
is that old or recent? No. It's old
one, actually. Okay. Let's not do that. Yeah.
So let's pop this open. Yeah. And let's
see if it's a static. Is it running
go?
Yeah. It's go. Oh, it should be okay.
Yeah.
The the path the path maybe is not
the right one. Like, the Yeah. You can
change the path. Like
I was looking for local
the destination. Yeah. Just
dot.
Okay.
Yep.
Makes sense.
Alright. I need to trim audit.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
It's not static.
Oh, it's not it's not static. It's linked?
Okay. Yeah. Dynamic is linked.
That's Alright. That's
a
yeah.
He seems to be used to
Yeah. I'm I'm getting so used to it.
I mean, Nexus has a lot of power,
but a lot of paper cuts all the
time, especially if it's not in next packages
or if it's not up to date in
next packages, it it it could be pretty
painful.
But we'll get that extra box just it's
only gonna take a minute, and then we'll
install it and just run from there.
Let's see if there's anything I can do
in the meantime. Do I need a Kubernetes
cluster locally?
Actually, Qovery is gonna, like, spin up everything
for you. You just need the docker runtime,
and that's it.
Okay. So yeah.
And
really, I should just start writing next shells
for all of these streams where I get,
like, a proper Linux file system and a
directory
just for stuff like this. Because, again, this
this is not the first thing this happens.
It's it's it's a common theme there.
Yeah. But it's good. It's good. It's, like,
re unscript.
It's it's live. Alright.
Wish I'd done arch instead of the door
now.
Okay. I I used to I used to
be a Debbie Allen guy
for a long time. It's been a while
now.
Yeah. Me too. Until Arch came along and
but I just rolling releases are
the best way. I always need the the
latest and greatest versions of packages, which Nextos
is generally really good for actually, especially these
days.
But there are always packages you find are
just that little bit behind where they need
to be.
Mhmm.
Alright.
So I might need to install the Docker
CLI, but that's okay.
Let's
get Qovery.
Again.
Qovery
off.
Alright. We're cooking.
Yeah. Perfect.
That's good.
You even have like, in the case that
you don't have
a brother, you can just type, like, dash
dash headless,
and you get, like, a code that you
can just validate. Like
Oh, no. DustroBox is the coolest thing I've
seen in a while. Like, I am in
a container. It is a fedora container, but
it hooks up everything to your host. Like,
I'm actually still in my own directory and
stuff like that. That's really nice. Yeah. Yeah.
It's really slick the way they've done it.
Yeah.
So great. Alright. You're authenticated now. You can
just, like, basically run ready for for this
command.
So we're gonna need a a Docker engine.
Right? Now does it need a Docker CLI,
or does it use a Go SDK?
I do think it's a bash
script, so we are using just the the
binary.
That's possible that we're using the binary. And
you see It's installing all the tools it
needs? Oh, no. Yeah. Yeah. I wanted Docker
though. It's
you don't.
It's okay. I can get Docker.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
But, yeah, basically, this command is here just
to install, like,
we do install what what did you install?
I do think
a Debian with, like, a k k three
s
that is running, and then we install, like,
the
different charts, the QWERADE. We do generate the
M charts, and we install the M chart
on it.
Yeah.
Let's see if it works.
At least on my side, it works.
Oh, we'll get there.
The the challenge is is the Internet in
my office has been, like, potato net for
a while now.
Oh, yeah. They they really need to fix
it.
Alright. It's getting there.
Okay. So
Qovery demo app.
Yeah.
Oh, there we go. This is all in
case three d.
Okay. That's
Installing how okay. So it's installing all the
tools, but it does expect Docker to be
on the host, which is fair enough. Right?
I mean, everybody has Podman, Docker, or something
like that running these days.
Yeah.
But this this command can be, like, flaky
sometimes because we do not control all the
environment, like, on your machines. So sometimes we
have, like, some weird issues. But,
yeah, in general, it works.
But it happens that it didn't work. Uh-huh.
So people, they fall back, like, on the
classic installer
of running that on their cloud account.
Or if they have already a Kubernetes cluster,
so they install
Qovery on it, and it just works.
So
yeah. But that's quite convenient here because you
can just run that command. Once you've you're
done, you can just drop, like, destroy run
the same command and destroy, like, the the
configuration.
Nice.
Yeah.
Alright. So it now appears to be installing
Qovery to the cluster.
Yeah. Congratulations.
I'll tell you what. I'll do you a
favor after this stream. I will update the
next package for you to the latest release.
Oh, if you're doing that, then you will
get, for sure,
a t shirt or
something.
Oh, yeah. I'll take it. Don't you worry.
That's good. Hopefully,
it's getting there. I mean, what's that installed
into the cluster right now? Like, what what
is that Qovery Home Chart doing here?
It's installing. So QWER is so it's written
in in Rust.
Okay? So we are installing, like, basically, the
binaries.
I can even share my screen, like, during
the installation so I can Yeah. Go for
it. How
how things work. So you will see it's,
like, public. It's quite it's quite interesting just
to get into that.
Doesn't support share. Mac OS is just
There you go. It's it's there. Oh, it's
mine. Okay. Perfect.
Yeah. So,
yeah, basically, we so how it works, it
it works this way. So you have the
control pane running on our side. Okay? And
you have the the Qovery binaries that they're
running on your Kubernetes cluster. So what we
do in style is that we create a
namespace, Qovery namespace, and we do install those
binaries. Those binaries,
they are
they are written in Rust. Okay? So that's
the part. Like, all those components, they are
like open source. So you can dig into
that, and you can see exactly how it
works. But, basically,
the way it works, you will see it's
very dumb,
but it's done in very good way. But
we interact with the Kubernetes API, but we
also do generate, like, all the configuration file
on the fly. So based on the configuration
and the stuff that you select
on the interface, and then they are translating
into the control plane. Okay. And you see
something which is quite interesting is that
our control plane is like a public API.
Okay? And your machine is not exposed. Right?
So you are installing QM recovery
on your own Kubernetes,
like local machine.
And what happened is that it's the cover
engine that is
getting the connections to the control plane and
not the opposite.
So which is like a reverse connection. And
then from that,
the cover engine your cover engine, when you
deploy an application and you do some operation,
actually, they pull, like, task from the control
plane. And then they are executed, and then
they report back
to,
basically, the control plane so you can get
the information from the interface.
Alright. Nice.
Yeah. Those are pretty cool diagrams. How'd you
make those?
It's Excalidraw,
of course. Scalidraw.
Nice. Yeah. But now I'm using t l
draw.
Now I don't know why I'm yeah. I
think we've got t l draw now.
I see. I like it's ScallyDraw because I've
got a Versus Code plugin, so I can
just pop up like a new window in
this. I mean, I'm sure TLDraw may have
one too. We now have Qovery clusters, so
I am gonna switch this back now.
Yep.
Ta da.
So I'm assuming
So now yeah. Hopefully, if
I come here
And you go back. We have a cluster.
Alright.
Let's click. I'm not even gonna look at
the tutorial. I'm just gonna start clicking on
buttons. But alright, I've got question there. Clicking
yeah. I'll let you click everywhere if you
want. There is no problem. I'll let you
discovering the product and what you have to
so, yeah, what you have to do. But,
basically, here so maybe I can just give
some explanations, but you are getting into the
settings of your cluster. So we have a
concept,
what we call advanced settings. So we'll not
cover that. But, basically, once you have your
cluster that is ready, okay, you can start
deploying application.
Okay.
And you see something very cool is that,
for instance, in my demo account, I have,
like, dozens of clusters. So you can have
clusters coming from anywhere,
AWS,
GCP, Scaleway,
Azure,
and you can plug them and unify the
work experience. That's why we have customers actually
that they're using Qovery.
So,
yeah, basically, yeah, you have to click here.
It's not super, so we are reworking on
that interface. But, yeah, that's exactly what you
need to do, actually.
Alright.
I'm gonna call it production.
Yep. I know it says I've got constraints,
but I wanna know what those are. So
I'm just gonna go straight and Yolo it.
Yep. I'm gonna click on settings first just
because I'm curious.
Uh-huh. Alright. Very nice.
Yeah.
Alright. Yeah. I'm I'm starting to get a
feel for this now.
Cool. What can I deploy? Let me see.
Yeah. Nothing complicated.
Nothing complicated?
So you can deploy an application
coming from, a GitHub rep. So you can
you can take do you have some codes,
like, on your GitHub repository,
for instance?
Sorry. Can you say that again? Yeah. Do
you have any applications available on your GitHub
repository
on GitHub account?
You mean, like, a deployment dot YAML?
Yeah. Or you can deploy oh, you can
deploy your hand charts if you want. We
have a very nice experience for that.
You can deploy your container directly from a
container registry. You can deploy an applications coming
from GitHub. So Qovery will clone the repository
for you, build
if you have a Docker file and so
on and so forth. So you can really
choose.
So just put yourself, like, in the shoes
of a developer. Okay? You are software engineer.
You are used to use a pass, and
you want to deploy in applications coming from
your Git repository.
Yeah.
Okay.
Container registry.
New registry.
Get go away with password.
Anonymous is fine.
And image name, oh,
Rawkode.
Mustard
v one. I'm gonna just check back. Yeah.
That's a that's a that's a good thing
just to to take a look at. Yeah.
Here we go.
Just
V one and v two. And and okay.
What's the what's the the image name? Like,
because it's longer than just that, I do
think. Maybe it's the
yeah. Oh, you find the tags as well.
Yeah. Great. Absolutely.
So we don't need to set that. It's
all done for me.
Okay.
Deploy me.
Woah. That's a lot. Do you have enough,
like, in your current time?
It's actually one core. Right? We we'll see.
We'll see. Yeah. It's one core. Yeah. Absolutely.
We'll see. We'll see. No problem if it's
not the case, actually. I mean,
this is a this is a nice machine.
Lucky you.
I'm the CEO. Supposed to have course.
Yeah. Now I'm the CEO. I'm not supposed
to have, like, a cool machine.
Yeah. Although you can see, it's just all
good Google Chrome.
Yeah. I don't even use Chrome. I use
Firefox, but I have to use Chrome for
streaming because not Firefox just can't do
multimedia. It's awful. Awful. Awful.
Alright.
It has a port six six six.
Let's publicly expose it.
Yeah.
And
Cool. Cool. Yeah.
Yeah. You you can set that afterwards,
actually, so you don't need to necessarily just,
yeah, do anything. I'm just clicking on stuff
now, to be honest. You're right. Just I'm
just curious. So You're right. We can set
the interface and see if the front end
team is is
good.
Alright. Let's see what happens.
Yeah. That's the most interesting part. So now
what you have done is that you have
created a service. And, actually, inside this environment,
you can create multiple services. So your database,
your different stuff. Oh, there is an error.
That's perfect.
Perfect.
Okay. Hit one.
So we got the It says to look
at my deployment.
I mean, I thought I was looking at
my deployment.
But, actually, it's just yeah. That's the yeah.
You're already on that. I'm just I'm looking
at the fade,
but we're all back into the version.
And Built to matter image.
What will be the error, actually? So if
you fade mirror image,
that's quite interesting.
I'm not sure about this. So we can
we can dig we we can dig into
that together, actually.
I'm
just gonna make sure.
Yeah. If you can just do that. But
we found the the image. So
Must be the one.
Really? Yeah. Docker emojis aren't allowed to use
mixed case.
Oh,
that's I wonder if that's the problem. That's
that's that's a that's a good so I
will report back that to my team. So
they they need to be very good. Yeah.
So now you get to add add a
service. Right? So Yeah. You you you can't
expect, like, developers just digging into that kind
of error. So when it happens,
it's kind of it's kind of messy for
them.
Alright. So it's now redeploying.
Yeah. Absolutely.
So you can look at the logs.
It seems happier.
Yeah. You can look at the
yeah, the details.
Yeah. Seems to be much, much, much happy
happier.
Yeah.
Well done. I'm now pulling it here.
You're now
Slowly pulling it here. But yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, come on, Internet.
You're fast open this.
Yeah.
That's a that's that's that's the counterpart of
of running that on your local machine. But
at least you you see and you get
the experience, like, it's
Well, let's do some hellos while we wait.
So hello, Mozz. Welcome back. Good to see
you again.
Thank you. Yep. You were here last time
too. Thank you for joining us again. Thank
you.
And we have a question.
Yeah. Y m o wants to know if
we're going to cover self hosting Qovery.
So
I know you set the control plan as
an open source.
What does that mean for people that are
in that kind of self hosting land?
Yeah. That's a very good question. Actually, we
are working on an enterprise version, like, for
next year. It's in our plan, like, just
to provide the ability to also self host
the control plane,
but only in
enterprise, like, offer just for, like, security compliance
reasons, mostly bank, for instance. They need that.
So, yeah, that's the options that we do.
Mozz has got a question for you. So
does Qovery support deployment to instances or virtual
machines? For instance,
can I manage
Ansible deployments with Qovery?
That's a very good, very good question. I
like that I like this question. Yeah. This
is real real world question,
and the response is yes.
Actually, Qovery is we use Kubernetes as, like,
an orchestration layer, And you can deploy Terraform
script. You can deploy your own Terraform module.
You can deploy your CloudFormation
script, Handsible script.
You can deploy anything.
And I'm gonna show you, like, a much
more complete, if you want, a pipeline where
we deploy such things like different type of
stuff. We even have customers actually that they
are only deploying Lambda application.
You imagine?
So, actually, they use Kubernetes just as an
orchestral year with Qovery, and they deploy Lambda
applications
for ephemeral environment to create dynamic environments for
testing purpose.
That's quite interesting. Right?
It's different, like, from the main use case
of using Kubernetes,
but Kubernetes is really good at just orchestrating
stuff.
So
Yeah. I think that the Kubernetes model,
if you're comfortable and happy to write controllers
that can live in there and engage in
that fashion, you can do a lot and
build a lot of really powerful software on
top of it.
You know, I was just to talk about
SaltStack that like, before Kubernetes, SaltStack was one
of my favorite pieces of software, but I
excelled at that exact use case as well.
Yeah. So Yeah. We have a deployment.
That's very good. So you can click on
for the overview,
for instance.
And this is something interesting. So now you
can just look at the you can open
the links. You see the links on the
the right the top right?
Uh-huh. Yeah.
You can open this link. It will work.
Is that not found? Like oh, maybe your
machine is not like do you ex oh,
yeah.
Is that supposed to to work like these
things or not really?
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
I mean
Is that working on your can you just
look at the
yeah. Quick. Quick. Quick.
Tick.
No. I
that's not gonna work because it's a cane
cluster. That's my oh, that is the cluster.
No. No. It's not the cluster. Yeah. You
can see the application. So it's running here.
Yes.
Mhmm. That's good. And Okay. So let's do
Yeah. Forward.
Yeah. Let's do that, and let's see. Apart.
666.
I'll just pick around 8080.
Oh.
Not found. Oh, the namespace? No. No. You
you missed the maybe the six.
You still need No. It's just the namespace.
Okay.
But
the part is, like, four times six. Right?
That's I know. I know it's three times
six or four times Three sixties.
Because it's part of custard, so it's the
number of the devil.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a good one.
So that field
for binding reasons,
means I probably got that the wrong way
around. Right? Because it should
I can never remember.
Okay.
So
local host.
Yeah.
Yeah. It it works
that way. Can you try something for me?
You see you have the access info.
Just try something.
Yeah.
You can local machine. So you have if
you you have a tab that is local
machine actually, so, Qovery, we do provide, like,
a way just to pull forward through
our CLI, and we have a system that
makes makes it possible because we install
a REST agent, like, that is forwarding
the thing through the control plane.
If you execute that command,
maybe that should be
the p, so it's something that is a
bit dumb, but we at the local.
And
yeah. Exactly.
Okay.
And now if you are doing local parts
That's that's probably
I don't know what's
maybe there is something that is not rooted,
like, properly, like, through this, yes, disengaged.
So
but, anyway actually, it works, so it's well
it's well, like, exposed. Right? Yeah.
And that's something you see. Actually, if I'm
look
so that's quite fun, David.
If I'm doing this command, you give me
access to your organization and you give me
the permissions to do that, like, to your
application.
From my machine here,
I can connect to your your application.
Nice. So you're running some sort of proxy
in the cluster that Yeah. Handles all of
the traffic. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. And it's the
reverse connection to the control plane. So everything
is transiting, like, the control plane, but nothing
is stored in the control plane because we
don't store any information for security purpose. So
it's all just proxy.
Okay. So I'm I'm I'm curious. Right?
We have deployed something.
Yeah. We've got a bunch of variables, some
of which I set myself.
Yeah.
But I didn't actually see a way
to expose these
to the workload?
To expose the the environment Yeah.
How how do I add the environment variable
to the workload?
Actually, they are they are. Like, they are
supposed to be in the workload. So Oh,
they are? Okay. So that's just done
for me. Yeah. The yeah. Again, put yourself
in the shoes of a developer.
They add environment variables. They add secrets. They
want just to see them.
Alright. Then I put this to you then.
One of the biggest frustration and I work
with a lot of people that need help
with Kubernetes.
Yeah. One of the biggest frustrations is they
have an environment variable or a config map,
and they come in and they say, okay.
Actually, that value is wrong,
and they save it.
Okay. So you offer to redeploy that for
me? Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
Yeah. Is there any status here that says
this is
sync? Yeah. You
have, like, you are supposed to have a
probably, like, you just a bar, like, saying
that you have to redeploy. For the environment
viable, maybe not. But if you are changing
any things like else, yes.
But,
yeah, you get the live status. So if
you are redeploying, you get the live status
and info from your your application. Yeah.
Okay. So okay. Now it's telling me that
this needs to be deployed for those changes.
Yeah. Okay.
Alright. Go for it.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Yeah.
So there is something also, like, that that
you you didn't click on is the service
logs. So you can see also, like, the
logs in real time of your application. You
have the tabs just to write to to
deployment logs, actually.
So, yeah, it was just next to
Mhmm. You have two tabs, deployment logs and
service logs.
Where's the service box? Oh, yeah. It was,
yeah, it was exactly in the same. You
see, you have two tabs
here. No. Actually, when you are just in
that in that console screen,
there's there's two tabs. I know that it's
a bit confusing. That's something that we are
working on,
but
you can just yeah. If you go you
go back, like, to the logs.
Yeah. Oh, right. Yes. Yes.
Exactly.
Right. Exactly. That's a bit confusing. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. Yeah. I completely
missed that. I just
Yeah. Right over my head. Service logs is
the logs, the live logs. Like, if you
were, like, doing Kube CTLs logs,
basically,
that you get, but in much more, like,
a detailed way.
Yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely.
That's nice.
Yeah. And this is transitioning
from directly the
so
from the control plane again. You see? So
Oh, I can switch pods.
I mean, I've only got one. Okay. That's
a really cool feature. I wanna play with
that. So I'm gonna come into my settings,
and I'm gonna say,
how do I scale this up?
Give
me three,
five. So I'm assuming this
see, the existence of InstanceMen and InstanceMax
tells me that there's probably some sort of
auto scaling that's being managed for me. I
haven't seen a way to set thresholds or
settings yet, so maybe you can lean into
that a little bit. But I just wanna
spend up more than one because if that
does what I think it does from the
terminal point of view, that's really cool.
But maybe you can tell us a little
bit about
where was that thing?
Services,
cluster
Yep. Settings.
Okay. So we have the ability to set
meta and max.
Do you handle auto scaling as part of
your control plan? Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
So the way it works is you can
so you have the default values. You can't
cover it as a video game. Okay? We
cover, like, 90% of your need
out of the box. Okay? We are just,
like, doing the things the way that most
people do. Then if you need to change
some internal parameters, you can get into the
advanced settings. So you see the tab that
you have on the left, advanced settings?
You can get into that. And this is
where you can start to tweak, like, the
internals and change, like, some specific parameters.
It's a key value stores like a system.
And, basically, you have HPA.
Like so if you are looking so if
you search for HPA,
you can you can find, like, the the
the way just to to change also, like,
the percent like, the CPU percentage for the
auto scaling part.
You see?
So,
yeah,
those are elements that we add
depending on, like, what our customers want and
yeah. Exactly. Recreate recreate is is available.
I'm just gonna break stuff now because it
was fun. No. That's good. That's good. Breaking
is good. I've turned on read only file
system. The application doesn't touch the file system,
so we should be alright.
I changed the deployment model to recreate,
which should speed up my deploys. But, obviously,
I'll I'll sacrifice and accept some downtime.
I don't wanna redeploy it just because, you
know, we have a deployment that I wanna
play with first. Right? So we can now
see that I have three pods.
Yeah.
And the thing that piqued my interest
was
this. Yeah. That's
so
oh, now I'm in the wrong pod. Okay.
Let's pop over here. Ah, that's nice. Okay.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Okay. That's a nice it's such a I'm
I'm sure
it's a simple feature in the back end
and all that. But to me, that's just
one of those, you know, when I find
a quality of life thing like that, it
just makes me happy because it shows that
people understand how hard it is to debug,
and you need to be able to switch
context, especially across pods within services.
Yeah. I'm so interested about it. So Even
even developers.
And just to to tell you, like, this
feature is not, like, an easy feature
because it works again, like, in real time.
It's IO, and we are playing. So I
know that my one of my staff, a
back end engineer, explained how we he did
that. So it's written in in Rust again,
and he's interacting directly with the Kubernetes API
just to stream the the input and the
output. But you have, like, some restriction,
and, also, you need to transfer back the
information to the control plane. The control plane
needs to transfer back those information in real
time via WebSocket
to,
like, the the browser. You see? So there
is some challenges, and we have some customers
that they are doing some crazy stuff, like
just streaming,
for instance, megabytes of data, you know, doing
those tail stuff. And and this is the
type of, like,
experience that just overload, like, the whole system
that can overload the system. So if it's
not, like, tailored, like, the right way. But,
anyway,
that's
I am now watching it stop all three
instances at the same time and, hopefully, spin
up three more for some pretty tightened up
resource restrictions.
But let's tackle a couple of questions just
now as well. So Mozz asked, is there
an ingress controller here? How are we handling
traffic to the cluster?
Yeah. There is an ingress controller. Yeah. Absolutely.
It's a ingress controller.
And, actually, when you install Qovery on your
Kubernetes cluster, you can tweak. So something that
you didn't see, David, because you are using
the demo mode, is that when you do
generate, like, for real, the configuration
with the CLI, the QCRI for your Kubernetes
cluster, actually, Qovery do generate for you the
final
hem charts, like hem values file. So you
can apply, you can change the parameters, and
you have access to those parameters like the
engine's eGAS controller and so on and forth.
Yeah.
I wanna make sure I understood that. So
Yeah. Let's pop over to production. Let's say
new service.
You're saying
if I pick a Helm chart, which I'm
assuming Postgres,
is that a Helm chart?
So it's a it's a yeah.
Under the hood, it's a it's a hand
chart. You're right. You're right.
But here, it's a it's a prebuilt, like,
hand chart. So we are doing so you
see, like, this fancy interface for developers that
they can use. But if you want to
deploy your Hemcharts, you if you want, you
can go just up, and you see you
have the Hem yeah.
And Hem integration is very good. Like, it's
very people,
most of the time, when they see how
we deintegrate that, they they really love, like,
even DevOps engineers,
actually.
Yeah.
Oh, I don't know where they are.
So it's TTPS probably,
I do think. Yeah.
Art backup.
Let's see if we can get our final
one.
Yeah.
And we have their own chart. Okay. I
love this product.
I'm spending 20%
of my day on Grafana looking at statistics
of stuff to report.
Yeah. It's
fantastic.
So alright. So you got the repository. You
scanned it and pulled down all the charts,
which I'm appreciating.
Nice.
Yeah. It's Grafana.
Yeah. Oh, let's go with Grafana.
Latest.
And something that you didn't notice, probably, David,
is that when you are looking, you know,
all those elements, version, Grafana, the chart name,
you can type directly with your your keyboard.
Actually, it will work, and it will filter
automatically, like, the the elements for you. Ah.
Yeah. So you can type directly the the
comment. That's something probably we need to improve
in the design system that we have.
Yeah. Oh, nice. Okay.
So I break everything.
I
Yeah. Oh, okay. So if I have a
values file in either my own GAML or
a public repository. Yeah.
Absolutely. And you you want to see something
very nice? Yeah. It's the whole mode, like
the whole YAML mode.
So he yes. And you create override.
Yeah. And here, we do load
to have the different values for you. Yeah.
And you can create your own one, like,
on the left. So it's good, like, just
to kick start quickly and do the stuff.
You need to add a feature where there's
a little arrow here, and I click it,
and it copies it over here. That's
that's a very good yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah.
Definitely.
Alright. I'm not I I want I think
you might
for the developer, they will just hate you.
But at least in terms of experience, it
will be very
nice.
Alright.
Go.
Alright. Another question from Miles while we wait
for to
to roll out. Do you support backup and
restore of persistent volumes?
So
we have also, we support, like, persistent volume
first. So you can add persistent volumes to
your application. You have an option to, like,
all the settings of your apps. Like, yes,
the settings, storage. Yes. Exactly.
Oh, that's something that is disable disable, like,
probably. Okay. Yeah. Probably because it's the demo
mode, and we have, like, some features that
you can add on the end values, because
you need to define, like, the storage type.
I do think that's the reason.
In terms of automatic backup and restoration,
no. We do not support that.
We didn't have, like, any request, and that's
the way also we work is that we
obviously, there's so many things that we can
do. The way we work is that we
have a public road map, and we are
very close to our customers so they can
just report back, like, the things that they
want
or they might want, and they can do
that. But
if there is a specific features into Qovery
that makes, like, everything possible,
is can you just show
this
maybe, David? So if you go back to
create a service
instead of creating a
so, yeah, if you go back here, new
service.
Yeah. You have the life cycle job. The
life cycle job is a
is a is a is
is basically a container that you will provide
so it could come from, like, a git
repository or container history where we'll execute that
task. So you can specify actions,
and we can and you can build your
own pipeline and your own stuff. So, basically,
you can execute comments. So let's say you
want to automatically backup
and restore stuff and you want to create
an action for that, you can do it,
and you can automate the whole process. That's
the way that, things like everything
possible, basically. Yeah. I hope I'm responding to
your question, Moses.
Alright. Thanks.
Yeah. I didn't really when we came to
this page, I didn't pay a lot of
attention to the first ones. I went straight
down to, like, okay. What's difficult to deploy?
But,
yeah, life cycle jobs are
that's a neat feature.
Databases.
Yeah.
Nice. Okay.
Yeah. And when you are running on your
own so if you use the query manage
option, let's say you run that into AWS,
you will get access to the manage databases
as well.
So meaning that here, we'll in just one
click, you can put in manage database, manage
progress, RDS.
Right. Okay. Yeah.
Which is convenient, like, for companies. Again, remember,
like, the perfect scenario is companies that they
are coming out of past. They wants to
move into The US. They are not super
familiar with all of that, so they just
wants to to deal with that.
Yeah.
Alright. So,
again, I'm just clicking on stuff,
but I'm curious because
Tell you. You're curious.
Well, I mean, that just means I'm excited.
Right? I'm enjoying what I'm seeing.
So
having built a lot of platforms,
what happens is, you know, we roll out
production.
We're all happy with it. At some point,
we need the staging environment. And what I
was hoping to see when I clicked I
mean, export is TerraFarm is nice. Right? I
wanna take into that a minute. I was
hoping for, like, a clone
to staging. Luke,
you have you have the option.
Oh.
Oh, you just made me happy. And I
can change the cluster so I could close
that to AWS or somewhere Yeah.
Oh, look at that.
That is a that is a pure joy
smile.
Yeah. That's a very, very, very we have
even Nasdaq companies that are using
Qovery just for that feature, just to tell
you, Because they can create their own environments,
and they can duplicate for their QA,
sales engineers, and stuff like that. They can
just duplicate
stuff once it's defined.
Okay.
And let's
click on export to Terraform now because I'm
curious what this does.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Downloads.
Unzip.
Where did it go? Oh, no. Send this
to alright. Okay. Main
variables.
Sorry for the light mode, everyone.
Yeah. Okay. So that is Qovery automation
for what I've been doing on the UI.
Right? Yeah. We have a telephone provider.
That's one more reason why
DevOps people, they like it because they can
control it everything
through our telephone provider. That's usually for pollution.
That's what happened is that at some point,
they do they start fast,
but then they move into, like, a GitHub's
way of managing everything.
And that's very convenient here because they can
start at least from something and then adapt
to what they need.
Okay. So this is a Qovery container.
Yeah. Yeah. We do maintain that for our
customer.
Yeah.
It's
it's our own provider.
Okay. So
now I mean, I'm I'm more curious now.
Production,
clustered,
settings,
storage,
no.
What happens if I then add a volume
to the TerraForm HCL?
Yeah.
Will it work?
If you add, like, a storage now, like,
an object, like, into that? Probably not.
I do think you will be rejected by
the by the API, actually. Right. Okay. Okay.
I was just curious.
Yeah.
I mean, it's nice that we can eject
away from the UI. And, again, you know,
the best can live and get
Yeah. And could be cloned and and reapplied
across different clusters and stuff like that. But
then I think when the UI
is right there,
it'd probably be inclined just to kind of
stick with this. I mean, the export is
nice. I I could have snapshots of point
in times, but I I I wouldn't I'm
not sure I would wanna jump back down
to modifying HCL.
Yeah. That's I guess that's the choice. Right?
People can decide what they want and what's
best for them. Yeah. Absolutely. And something that
we are working on is that we are
more and more we have more and more,
like, software engine, one side, DevOps that they're
using the platform and controlling it. What we
want to do is that when a mode
so that's something that will come, like, next
year. But, basically, when you modify the web
interface,
instead of applying the changes
Yeah. Instead of applying the changes right away
into the API
and doing those changes, we'll
to deny, like, the top configuration and update,
like, the gateway,
like, appearance of it in the overview and
then apply. And then
Yeah.
Usually, people today, they choose one or the
other.
Nice.
Alright.
I think we've kicked the tires on we
I mean, we don't even use the get
started page. Right? We just let me go
click happy on your UI, which is which
is nice.
But I feel like, you know, we have
showed people a small
contrived example, but powerful example of what people
could can do with Qovery.
Is there anything else that you want to
show people that gives them a snapshot or
a look into what
you or your customers or production deployments look
like with Qovery?
Yeah. I can I can show I can
show maybe, like, a few things? So maybe
a much more like a
so maybe a much more
detailed
configuration.
K. You happy for me to to throw
your your screen up? Yeah. My screen yeah.
Yeah. You can. Yeah. Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah. I can I can show, yeah, I
can show a much more, like,
bigger view, like, of different type of services
that they're running on on on the coverage?
So this is a an environment containing,
like, a production,
but, actually, it's not. It's just for my
my test.
But here, you have a bunch of so
it's running on AWS on a managed cluster.
And, actually, this cluster has even, like, Kubernetes
Carpenter turned on. We have an integrations with
Carpenter, so we do install and manage that
with our manager for. So meaning that I
can benefit from the spot instances and the
the downscale part, like, of this, know, the
the scaler, which is great. K? And,
basically, here,
you have, like,
back end, front end databases,
even Terraform script. That's what I wanted just
to show you. So you see I've deployed
RDS instance with my own Terraform module,
and this module is just
is just that. You know? Look. It's a
pure
Terraform script. Okay? So
where I declare my resources,
and I have, like, some inputs and some,
like, output and variables. So I can define
that. And you see,
the beauty here is this. Because once you
have executed this Terraform script from Qovery, you
want to get back the informations from, like,
the endpoint, username, password that they are do
generate it at the end time. And even
that, we do manage that properly into Qovery.
So when you start deploying Terraform script,
look. I got the job output values
that they are available, like, at the execution.
And that's what makes, like, Qovery so powerful
because here, actually, what you get is a
deployment pipeline.
So all my services, I can just execute
in the right order. I can deploy in
the right order of my different
services, so even my Terraform RDS.
And when it happens, like, Terraform is that
those output values, they are injected into the
other services. They are available to the other
services
at the time of the execution.
So you see? So that that's something that
is very, like, much more much closer than
than ever, like, to the to the production
to something that runs, like, from our customers.
And, yeah, I just wanted to show you
that because,
obviously, when you you deploy one application, it's
very simple. But when you need to interconnect,
like, microservices
applications altogether and just order the right way
those different services, then this is why it's,
like, much more harder.
And we cover, like, all of that, obviously.
And you can clone just for your own
you can clone even that environment, David. So
I can choose, like, even another, like, a
cluster. So for instance,
let's say Tokyo cluster
on Google,
I can just clone that one. Obviously,
the RDS,
so will not be, like, properly working. So
you you can adjust and adapt, like, based
on the the meta informations that you have
from Qovery.
But, yeah, you can clone, like, all the
resources.
Very cool. I like that.
Yeah.
And if you just go to that pipeline
where we see that phased rollout
Yeah. If you go to the pipeline, you
get exactly the same. Alright. So it like,
will that update and say, oh, there's an
SQS there, which isn't gonna work on GCP.
Right? But, you know, I was curious if
it visualized
the progress through the pipeline from left to
right.
No. No. No. But that's something that we
want to bring, like, a much more, like,
visual view of when something is deployed. But
today,
when you do deploy, a a pipeline
so if I redeploy this, for instance, pollution,
you you you can see, like, from the
logs interface, you have a
view Nice.
Of the pipeline. Yes. You have the first
stage here that you can create. You can
customize everything, but you have the first stage,
then the second stage, third, and so on
and so forth. So you can see you
see, boom,
here, like, the
the deployment of the different resources that they
are done in parallel in each stage.
So if something goes wrong and that's something
that is very nice because
when you deploy an environment, like, your service
can go wrong, so you can just see
exactly which one at which time, and you
can troubleshoot that service, and you can redeploy
just that service or set of service and
so on and so forth.
Awesome. I like that.
Alright. I'm gonna push this back to is
there anything else you want to show before
I I push this back to back face
mode?
No. Actually, you know, otherwise, we can spend,
day. Yeah. I mean, it was it was
daytime when I started the session and it's
Yeah. That's good to hear. Alright.
Let's wrap this up. Maybe you could share
a little bit about, you know, I I
think you've you've given us the history about
you and and Qovery. We've seen the product.
I think a lot of people are really
gonna enjoy what they see.
What's next? What what what's what's on your
road map?
Yeah. Yeah. That's a very good question.
So the goal for us is to use,
like, the integration as much as we can.
We have worked on the AI agent that
is open source and have, like, our customers
to transition very easily, like, from past solutions
to, yes, using covering in just, like, no
time. Today, it works from to AWS and
the different those account provider. In just five
weeks, we can move out the workload. That's
crazy. That's something that were not even possible,
like, before
LLM.
That's really it's interesting. We can drop the
link because it's available on GitHub.
But, basically, we focus on that, And then
there is, like, many more that we we
want to provide, like, supporting
also providing, like, Azure
managed, like, offer. That's something that we are
working on. And you talk about that, but
those enterprise features that we want, like the
self managed
control plane, that's something also we want to
deliver.
But, yeah, the product is, like, evolving all
the time. We have invested a lot, like,
in the developer experience, and we are eager
just to get feedback from users when you
see something so we can just,
like, work on it. But those are, like,
the main the main big things that we
are working on. Yeah. Nice. Awesome.
Alright. Well, I mean, thank you so much
for taking time out of your day to
sit here, talk about your product, show it
to people. And, yeah, it's been an absolute
pleasure. I think it's a fantastic
developer experience and user interface on what is
a pretty cumbersome and and difficult challenge for
many people and many teams and many organizations.
And I hope that it will vary for
the people that are out there going I
need this. We'll solve some real challenges for
them. So, you know, thank you again.
Yeah. Thanks, David. Thanks for letting me take
a stab at everyone. Alright. And then thank
you to everyone for watching, you know. Feel
free to say goodbye in the comments as
we write this out. We'll see you all
next time. And, Rawkode, thank you again. I'll
speak to you soon. Bye, all. Goodbye.
End of stream, let's leave our Rawkode
Academy
session done. Now we wait for the next
one.
Learning cops, we all connect.
Knowledge gained, we all reflect.
Tech talks and the coding grind in the
stream we all didn't find. Thanks for joining
Vans for the thrill.
Every moment, every skill.
Hope to see you next time, Rawkode
Academy.
Tech about